Milk.
The civilized way to drink it is out of a
glass versus guzzling it out of a jug.
Unless, of course, you're celebrate
a win at the Indy 500.
But it was no victory
when a Canadian real estate agent
got caught on surveillance video,
opening the fridge
and chugging out of the milk
jug for about 6 seconds
alone in Lescott Fullerton's home,
waiting to show it to potential buyers.
Why? Why?
Why would somebody do that?
Mike Rose almost closed the fridge,
then opened it again
for another lingering look.
The Fullerton's we're angry,
having each lost a parent to COVID.
The idea of it
just so that it just grosses me out.
Because of the way he got milk
Mike Rose
got whacked with almost 17,000 U.S.
dollars in penalties and costs.
The British Columbia Financial Services
Authority calls
it conduct unbecoming.
The homeowner confronted Rose last summer
when the episode happened.
I asked him, I said,
Is there anything you want to tell me
about the last time you were in my home?
And he said, Oh, the milk incident.
He was just so nonchalant about it.
Fullerton says he also accidentally
broke her couch by sitting on the arm.
CNN wasn't able to reach Rose, but
he has apologized for his very unfortunate
and very unclear
touristic decision
telling local outlet CFTC.
I have never done
this kind of thing before, nor
will I ever behave in this way again.
He told the authority
he was unusually dehydrated
because he was taking new medication
and under considerable stress.
What did you do with the milk?
I threw it away.
Hide your milk when Mike's around.
Wrote one joker on Rose's Facebook.
He's had to move to a new real estate
firm.
Mike Rose found out what
the star of Anchor Man already knew.
Milk was a bad choice.
Jimmy must CNN get a glass.
You don't just get across New York